Brendan's drive her car the car he
drives every day on them I ever did
number one every day car the GTC large
this is the gt2 RS very important seller
yeah it was an mr cao now in keeping
with the times
Brendan's Porsche the car he drives
every day has fire fire coming out of
the exhaust has the ability to shoot
funny because he had it soup to 900
horsepower cuz that's what you need on
the 4 or 5 now listen there's no traffic
right now there's no traffic but but
still can be traffic right but your boy
might be in Texas who was no traffic yes
but but so so we can't know that car
that car is aerodynamic that car
actually can fly I don't know if let you
guys know that but he has the ability to
get it off the ground and fly through
the air and he just needs a couple of
small wings on the job Airlines its sha
sha Breeland it's called sha Barons only
fit now I have a roll cage so we have no
back seats as the world burned there's a
roll cage in the back now as we have
racial turmoil as we have kovat 19
Brendan decides I got the answer I'm
gonna soup my car up to 900 horsepower
and I'm gonna drive around with fire he
sent me a video of fire coming out of
that Chris OS
my question supplier now to close like
like it was it's like half a dragon he's
got a dragon car it's so funny the
different dynamics of our friends cuz I
said to you and Chris and you know you
guys make fun of me I think the Rogen he
does goddamn I love that of course he
does
Rogen the extremist motorist I read you
know well are extremists but you took
there's in our group of friends there's
only three car enthusiasts it's and this
is he's kind of he lays low about it but
who may wait I might know you so it's
you it's Rogan it broke Rogan out says
number one is way more cars than me okay
it's you and out now the fast car out of
any of them so watch your P's and Ken it
might be I know Russell Peters loves
cars uh he loves cars but he's not a no
he's not a gear okay we know we know
Corolla and we know oh whoa
well crow I'm not cruel stalking more of
the crew okay so you trying I love her
all things that look
my mother crew um I don't know you see
like Tommy Stewart crew yeah it's a girl
Oh is he big cart guy I didn't know that
big he's a he's you don't talk about it
you know he's not like me to tell people
what he does and big car guy he's a big
car guy big car guy really he's super in
his you know crazy oh yeah
he's like me let's take some yesterday
I'm like why are we like this he's like
I don't know we're constantly pushing
the boundaries I'm like there's nothing
that I can't do anything else like
that's the as facet that it reset the
record had more horsepower it's so weird
but wait do you hear it no I'm sure he
brought it last night I was like oh dude
we have to leave it outside he goes why
I'm like it's gonna wake my kids up my
neighbors gonna be pissed it's so loud
that's your car yeah - race car well
gentle give ideo okay well listen you
know congratulations I mean oh there we
are let's see this it's a banshee and
this is I didn't open up the valve sir
the camera can't capture the actual
audio it's so loud so they can ask oh it
sounds pretty bad
listen that air whistle no turbo I send
you the video of it shooting fire on the
highway chain know how to get it for the
fans so they know what's the 101 there
now is that a certain mode you're in
right now no I mean I'm in manual so
when you rev it up and slow down the
revving up again as you know right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]